I'm Chris card hair Comic Con 2018 San
Diego showing off my superpower which is
telling people where their superpower
could be this is plausible power
generator do I get any cool effects I
think I should get some cool effects
coming off my feet
what's ooh why would you want like what
does your mama we scream at you about
doing what do you always get in trouble
for you can hop on a trash bag and fly
whatever you want do you like this power
yes super but you always have to take
out the trash that's the only thing you
have to take out the trash now remember
the juice from the trash bag does drip
onto the ground so you will saw you two
people underneath you
if you could have any superpower what
would it be what is your worst trait
okay so what's your power be is whenever
you're meeting to somebody because
mortal but as long as you're nice to
people you have more time next question
what is the trait that people say is
that kind of your worst trait what do
you think it'll be okay you will be able
to cure someone's disease but for the
next 24 hours you have to have that
disease I take it so what do you figure
out your add to my diet I've actually
just fixed some things I'm doing some
things wrong and invisibility okay now
next question what is your worst trait
what does your trade the people say oh
if you could you could fix this you can
become better your supply would be that
you can only affect time when you're
meditating
organization yeah you can't fly you
cannot fly until your house is
completely clean are we doing it are we
selfie oen selfie mode I heard you're
vegan that's a pretty awful trait now if
I had to give you a power what your
power would be anything that comes in
front of you two enters your mouth it
automatically becomes vegan that's it
you don't have to ruin dinners anymore
so you can only time-travel when you're
doing something good
yes basically if you're about to win the
game yeah you never see the end of the
game you oh you never get the
satisfaction who could teleport but only
when you get annoyed you can't fake it
either like you got to be really in your
heart your pals awful I guess so but I
mean what's the worst trait that thing
that people don't really love about you
too much you're a slavish
you're sloppy you're very sloppy every
time you make something messy another
room gets clean only bad thing about
this is when you clean a room
you dirty upper room half your life is a
mess the other half is clean mister do
all your men Wow deep isn't it deep I'm
out of here
[Music]
you